I didn't see this coming to be honest
based on feedback
I saw you love taking a look back at
some nice anime rematches so I decided
to take a break from regular programming
and bring along content that you can't
get enough of a good rivalries nice and
a good rivalry with some memorable
rematches completely takes the cake
after going through a list of great
anime rematches once it's time to run it
back and go for it again you ready let's
go
first off we have our first sibling
confrontation with a car mate versus
Koroma the siblings had their fair share
of truss ups in economy got killed
there's no love lost between them ever
since Corot Mays introduction and with
her neck romantic abilities she provides
a great match for a sister who's taken
the good side even their swords or polar
opposites with economies causing instant
death while Kuro Mays sword brings the
dead back to life with drugs enhancing
her abilities kurume takes the fight to
her sister in their final decisive
confrontation the fierce battle starts
out even with how well match the sisters
are in the end the battle comes down to
a final charge by both and ends with
Kuro mate being impaled by more Asami
Kuro mate may be one of the most
psychopathic villains but I think few
shed its here at the battles conclusion
Goro may and waves relationships another
story and I can't deny seeing it end
like this isn't sad in the slightest an
interesting thing to note here is that
their final fight is a different ending
in the manga I won't spoil the fates of
the characters in the manga you're just
gonna have to read that one yourself
first impressions matter a lot when
Akutagawa introduced himself to the
group he showed off the power of Russian
one something that made a mark on at
sushi who found himself struggling
against the shadow powers threatening to
devour him thankfully Darcy's
intervention saved him from the worst
and our hero lives to fight another day
at Hsu she returns for a rematch by
saving Kyoko from Akutagawa at first it
appears as though accout the girl was
giving himself an easy win with Rashomon
before Atsushi emerges and clocks his
jaw with a clean punch this causes a
good the gawe to reveal more techniques
with Rashomon but no matter what he does
he just can't put his rival down for
good
Akutagawa pulls out everything from
russia wants versatile arsenal but even
that's not enough to overcome at sushis
willpower as it's so strong it allows
him to overcome spatial distortion in
order to defeat Akutagawa decisively
talk about coming back from a previous
defeat to win in style
[Applause]
we go to the Viking period for us
seventh entry tour fiat vs torque L
round two in their first battle aboard a
ship things didn't end well for our hero
so when the prospect of a rematch comes
up things still don't look good for him
however this is a stronger tothen than
before and with a skill adds fate on the
line he'd probably be able to put up
more of a fight this time round
even with his resolve shaken tore friend
brought the fight to his far superior
ponent even coming away with clean hits
this time round eventually thanks to a
distraction from a scolaire tour
Finland's a kick straight at talk Hill's
head and brings down the giant and if
that wasn't enough he manages to gouge
out talk Hills eyes as well
ouch
[Applause]
titans bring the house down in their
clash that gets featured on this list
with entry number six
Aaron vs. Reiner Aaron and Reiner had
their first battle around the time the
latter revealed himself to be the
armored Titan battling Aaron in his
Titan form Reiner comes out with the win
after help from the colossal Titan
expect Aaron to make a stronger showing
in their rematch and boy did he deliver
not only did Aaron piss Reiner off by
skillfully dodging the latter's punches
he rendered whiners defenses useless
against his newfound powers after all
what's armor to the unstoppable force of
post experiment Aaron's punches to be
fair Ryan he gets the upper hand a
couple of times but he soon finds
himself at a grave disadvantage against
Thunder Spears more action and a run in
from the colossus typed and follows but
we'll leave that one for another day
because as of now Aaron's tied the
series against Reiner up at one apiece
will there be a third fight between
these two watch the final season later
this year to find out
as divisional teams Alba Joe site also
called say Joe and karasuno have a
rivalry brewing leading the charge for
iover Joe site is their star setter way
cover who started off the series making
a strong impression in the inter high
preliminaries the teams faced off unlike
what happened in the earlier entry
featuring Kuroko the first match here is
a much closer affair seemingly destined
to face each other they meet once again
in the spring High Representative
playoffs the grand finale of haikyuu
second season as expected from the hype
the match is gripping full of twists and
is every bit intense
in the end karasuno tough this one out
with clever tactics narrowly edging
their longtime rivals finishing their
revenge match against the team that once
cut their journey to the top short with
a revenge match behind them the scores
now officially one apiece will we see a
third match between these two teams I
definitely hope so
[Applause]
you could at least Dimity
cool
present it as a complete enigma Hisoka
has got to be one of the coolest
characters in hunter hunter the
dangerous character gets introduced as a
potential rival and has his first fight
against the Kiros in the hunter exam arc
where he easily takes care of business
defeating gone and Larry OH after his
sokka's words about God's potential
everyone's got to be excited to see that
potential in action when they meet again
thankfully we don't have to wait that
long as the to face off once more in the
heavens arena Ark this time gone shows
off that talked about potential by
coming up with a clever tactic to get
the upper hand on his opponent while GaN
was truly outmatched in his first fight
against Hisoka
this time it's gone who takes the
initiative and gets the jump on his
opponent landing a clean punch
unfortunately that strike can be the
last of God's clean offense in the end
our hero still gets trounced despite
putting up more of a fight than before
however he gets words of praise from his
opponent so that's gotta count for
something hasn't it gone has more room
to grow and when he reaches his
potential and the two have another go at
it his so-called better watch out dude a
national scene conservancy idea
being the charismatic main villain that
years it's inevitable that arguably Tok
asougi's most awaited fights the one
against kintoki where the to settle it
or good friends with kintoki and Katsura
events at the end of the war had turned
him against the two and in episode 304
of Gintama he looks to settle the score
with Ginn Toki once and for all the two
squared off in an emotional doubleheader
episode that caps off the excellent
Shogun assassination arc as their past
slowly unravels to the audience the two
fighters push each other to the limit
resorting to physical combat after
simultaneously losing their swords the
emotional fight highlights kintoki
sparing his enemy and the two showing
mutual understanding before he gets
forced to an abrupt ending it's the
climactic fight that everyone who
watches Gintama knows he needs a blood
feud revolving around two former friends
turned bitter enemies is a surefire
recipe to create a big time rematch
that's why this battles not the last
that we'll be seeing of its kind after
all a runner-up at or somewhat similar
in circumstance
two sides of the same coin Kakashi and
obito are as perfect as force can be
both in terms of philosophy and
disposition despite that they do have
one major similarity similar eye powers
making them the perfect match for one
another as they battle inside Kamui in
Naruto's endgame arc in terms of build
up I think few fights in Naruto can beat
the final battle between Kakashi and
obito especially after all the
revelations that come before if this
fight awesome enough to be one of the
best of the decade and I'd encourage you
to see for yourself the great
choreography and exchange weaved by two
similar combatants the backstory action
and emotion carried this fight so hard
blood feuds bill through arcs and long
backstories are a treat but the one
fight that tops the list needs none of
those in fact the feud starts and
finishes within a pretty short time span
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes rematches don't need to build
hype whereas our runner-ups a match
that's several years in the making this
top one doesn't take so long after their
first conflict was interrupted Nanashi
and luo lang finally meet once more at
the climax of sword of the stranger the
powerful Luo Lang's finally met the
worthy opponent he's been waiting for
and it's on Luo Lang strength needs no
further hype after tearing through
people one-man army style among other
feats everyone knows what Luo Lang's
capable of Nanashi has to bring more
than a hundred percent to overcome the
toughest challenge he has to date the to
fight all around the altar at length
Nanashi triumphs despite sustaining
numerous injuries from his fearsome
opponent what I like about this battle
is there's no need for a complicated
backstory about the two despite not
having arch dedicated to a rivalry
despite the characters not going through
episodes or chapters of build up is a
movie of course the hype still there
because of the amazing fight
choreography animation and of course the
music it's no surprise that this fight
is regarded as one of the best sword
fights in anime it's a jaw as clean as
it can possibly get and that makes no
gnocchi's victory all the more
satisfying
so how does this second list look them
does volume to have better rematches
than volume 1 of this list in case you
haven't seen the first list do make sure
you go and check it out I have a link
right there and you can go compare the
two lists to see which one has your
preferred rematches as usual like and
subscribe if you enjoyed the content and
stay tuned for more Vinny Tube goodness
in the coming weeks
[Music]